Now, when we have a character followed by a star or a question mark, that's the hardest part, let's save that for last.
Now let's consider the final case--and the final case is when we know that the pattern is not empty,
and we know that we've gone through all the special characters. So the first character is not a special character,
except maybe it's a dot, because we haven't dealt with dot yet.
And so we want to match the first character, and then we want to match the rest of the pattern,
whether that's empty or whether it's something more.
So what I'm going to do is invent a new function that I call match one, and that matches a single character,
and we want to return "true" if that single character which is the first character of the pattern matches against the text,
and if we can recursively match the rest of the pattern against the rest of the text.
So this is saying, "We don't have a special character here, except maybe a dot,"
and so we have like b followed by a, we want to match the b against the text,
and then we want to match the A against something else.
So fill in for me here what I should be matching against to match the rest of the pattern against the rest of the text.